Adam Schefter joining us part of SPN
Sunday NFL countdown as well as Monday
night countdown and this week Mexico
City Chiefs Chargers Monday Night
Football Adam thanks for joining us how
are you doing hey Dan how was your 40th
reunion or where they were Union back at
ESPN from the 40th anniversary week in
fact I think a chance to ask you that it
was it was strange but it was fantastic
because it's changed so much and oh yeah
you know but to be able to go back there
and then I once I sat down with Oberman
and we just then we kind of blocked out
everything else and we're basically back
to where we were and Scott Van Pelt was
very generous with our time and you know
it was nice it was nice but you know to
do it and not have the ESPN fanfare
attached to it where we kind of
surprised some people that was what was
enjoyable but uh it was great was great
that they could have you back and it's
going to take you know how much it's
changed like I I'm gone for a week and I
come back in things I was surprised that
you didn't break the news so I do glaser
beat you to it though alright finish
this sentence if the Cleveland Browns
lose tonight tonight we're gonna see the
pressure ratcheted up on Freddie
kitchens which is no surprise there and
we have certainly seen a history of
Cleveland Browns firing their head
coaches after washes to the Pittsburgh
Steelers their last six head coach all
right
that's the Pittsburgh Steelers so again
do I think pretty kitchens being fired
tomorrow I'm not telling each other it's
not like that but I'll say this when
you're at ten days to stir after a loss
like that when you basically gone to
three and seven your season is over at
that point um what do you think the
conversation is going to be like how
many job openings do you foresee in the
offseason well today if we go back to
2000 you we averaged about six point
seven a year and some years it's more
some years less obviously but you can
always bank on it being right around
that number now
I'd have to go back and look last year I
think it came in slightly below that
slightly below that I see the numbers
and I haven't I haven't delved into this
just yet the study of numbers of that
but my guess is we'll get five or six
this year just just a guess cuz we
usually do yeah you start to and I know
that there's a lot of season left to be
played and if Cleveland somehow goes on
a run and ends up nine and seven and
maybe Freddie kitchens keeps his job or
Jason Garrett goes to the NFC title game
maybe he keeps his job on a losing
streak yeah and you lose that you lose
five of its last six whatever's and
we're gonna start talking about a cop
who an expected losing his job lose his
job like that it just happens you every
year the team most likely to sign Colin
Kaepernick is who impossible to say
because he's not playing this year so I
see people saying well Detroit needs
help there right now they've got Jeff
Driskel starting and David allow backing
them up and whatnot
Colin Kaepernick if he were to sign if
you were to sign yeah I think would be
signed to a futures contract for 2020 so
who knows how everything's viewing is
quarterback situation for next year and
yet they want to add or decisions that
they'll be make too literal you'd have a
1 in 32 chance at guessing where Colin
Kaepernick would wind up landing that
sir I believe a guy I guess I guess
you're gonna have to have something of a
liberal open-minded owner right I think
that we so we probably could knock out
some people there but honestly it could
go any which way with that because every
team will assess its quarterback
situation I don't care one team you
could look into for this this team is
likely to sign Colin Kaepernick for 2020
I got a theory does you know it's like
when you're a lawyer you don't ask a
question that you don't know the answer
to could the NFL be asking a question
that they know the answer to and that is
we're going to give you the opportunity
to work out Colin Kaepernick you know
it's like when I think
they told Jeff Fisher in the Rams to you
know draft Michael Sam you you know use
a draft pick because this is historical
it feels like the NFL does know the
answer to this workout this weekend and
it's it this is just a theory on my part
what do you think what do you make of
that a couple of things there first of
all you're surmising that the work at
this weekend is going to happen and I'm
still not convinced of that just yet
number two I understand what you're
saying about suggesting that they may
know the answer the question you're not
the first person to have suggested that
it's just I guess it's hard for me to
grasp that a player who has not had a
single work at a single visit a single
tryout in two years and eight months who
teams are just shunned who is a mmm
enormous ly polarizing figure and
historical figure but a polarizing
figure where some people love him and
some people despise him the NFL's got an
arranged with a team to go sign the sky
already like I don't know that what's
that's I don't know I mean listen the
NFL is that powerful and the NFL does do
what it wants and the NFL can get things
done at a moment's notice but this is a
different it's a different case now is
it different case but I don't understand
why this is happening and it's so
hastily called Adam because the NFL was
out of the Colin Kaepernick business you
had the collusion like they had moved
past this it's week 11 of the season and
then all of a sudden you know NFL
writers get a heads-up we got a big
announcement on Tuesday and then you
tell Kaepernick and then hey teams get
together why not do this in March why
now it's it honestly that we don't have
an answer my theory and it's just a
theory
is that this is the NFL's response to
Colin Kaepernick steam releasing its
statement to correct the quote/unquote
false narratives end of quote that
existed about Colin Kaepernick which was
a two-page statement at least October
10th that detailed what equity our
factual
all things about colin kaepernick in
this case and they wanted to be spelled
out this way that he has not had a visit
he has not been called he has not had a
workout he's been training five days a
week for three years and still not
gotten anything his numbers are better
than most of the quarterbacks that are
in the way he can adapt any system he's
willing to go to any system it was a
whole two pages of sheets of information
and I think the NFL didn't like to lose
control of the Colin Kaepernick
narrative and and they did open it up
and it surprises me too because going is
having a great season it's been nice and
peaceful it's been enjoyable
we got Lamar Jackson and Sean Watson
playing this week we got a game in
Mexico City there's a lot of great
storylines and now we're back to this
now we're back to this the whole can of
worms has been open I said to somebody
the other night I said I don't get it
like don't you want to move past this
and someone said to me I would they
think there are people with within the
league I don't know that like this that
want this which I can't believe but that
was what one person said the other night
and so here we are again so you know
that it could it's such a polarizing
topic you know I've gotten texts and
calls from people boy this guy has
gotten notes screwed over and he
deserves another chance and I've gotten
other texts like how could they even
consider this guy you know like one guy
texting last night your wife lost her
husband 911 how could you even want this
guy's a community like hey it's great
but that's the kind of emotion that he
arouses in people and the NFL by itself
by itself what the issue back on the
front burner they made that decision
because Colin Kaepernick you know
anything about this proposed workout
that came about Thursday Antonio Brown
as you tweeted out meeting with the NFL
any chance that he's playing this season
his agent Drew Rosenhaus disagrees with
me and again on Sunday we reported that
he's not expected to play this year
there are just so many factors involved
he was not fully cooperative with the
NFL and turning over evidence that the
league requested the league dragged this
case along so both sides were
disappointed with the other in this
particular investigation there has to be
a decision do we know that the decision
is going to go his way is it going to be
a quick decision I still think that
there's gonna be potential discipline
Fran Tonio Brown were already going into
week 11 mmm it's hard for me to imagine
he's gonna play for his team this season
I do think he's gonna get a chance next
season now drew says he believes this
meeting will go on today he'll be
cleared and you'll be signed shortly
thereafter and that's Cruz opinion and
he's his job is to represent his client
I think it's gonna take longer than that
and based on the conversations I've had
with various people I don't believe he's
going to play again this season we'll
see who's right
Adam great to talk to you again buddy we
appreciate your time as always Dan come
back to Bristol any time or the next
time Thank You chef T that's Adam
Schefter for more Dan Patrick show tune
in to audience Channel 239 on DirecTV
streamed for free on BR live or download
the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]